Ever wonder why some people cry when they’re
happy?
Well, psychologists may have just figured
it out!
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and if you’re
the type of person who cries tears of joy
during happy moments - you’re not alone.
Tons of people do it, but the question is
- why?
Well now, science has an answer.
Oriana Aragon, a psychologist at Yale with
possibly the coolest name ever, has been conducting
a series of studies to figure out why people
cry when they’re happy.
According to her study, which will be published
soon in the journal Psychological Science,
crying tears of joy - may be a way for us
to restore emotional equilibrium.
It’s not uncommon for us, she says, to respond
to positive experiences with negative emotions,
whether it’s crying when we’re happy,
or screaming out of excitement, or even pinching
an adorable baby’s cheeks.
When you think about it, in the most basic
sense - all of those are negative reactions
to an otherwise positive experience.
So Aragon and her colleagues, decided to run
subjects through some of these scenarios and
measure their responses.
What they found, is that people who expressed
negative reactions to positive events, were
also capable of recovering from those emotions
much more rapidly than people who didn’t.
And those kinds of reactions tend to happen
across the board.
Meaning that someone who cries at their children’s
graduation, is also the type of person who’s
most likely to pinch a cute baby’s cheeks.
But it’s not just a one-way street.
According to Aragon, there’s also evidence
that strong negative feelings can lead to
positive expressions.
Nervous laughter in an awkward or difficult
situation, would be a good example.
At the end of the day, it’s all just a way
of restoring equilibrium.
What do you guys think, are you the type of
person who cries easily during happy moments?
Let us know your thoughts in the comments
down below - and as always, thank you guys
for watching!